foreign
have you ever been thinking about how to
integrate sustainability into your
business values stay tuned to find out
how Google Cloud can help
hi I'm Ella and I'm Valeria and we're
both customer Engineers here at Google
Cloud welcome back to the technical
guides for startups a video series where
we help startups to start build and grow
their business successfully and
sustainably on Google Cloud
in the previous video we looked into the
looker product family and showed you how
to explore analyze and share business
insights
today at our start at zero guide we will
cover how you can optimize your business
sustainability by starting with Net Zero
technology admission or starting Q move
towards net zero we are going to come
why sustainability matters and why it is
an important consideration for your
business
we will share Google sustainability
strategy operating as the cleanest cloud
in the industry we'll cover how Google
Cloud supports you on a sustainability
journey through two key pillars digital
sustainability and operational
sustainability and we'll show you what
this looks like in the Google Cloud
console
and we'll also take a look at an example
of one of our customers who is
partnering with Google Cloud to start at
xero all right let's start with a key
question to answer why sustainability
matters
sustainability has three main pillars
economic environmental and social
to achieve sustainability we need to
balance all those factors with equal
Harmony
in business sustainability is about
doing business without negatively
unpacking the environment Community or
society as a whole
out of many there are two key reasons
startups should think about
sustainability topic
the first and often more compelling for
business
is that there is a consumer demand and
therefore investor demand
most consumers and investors are making
purchase and investment preferences
based on environmental impact
retail and institutional investors are
building sustainability metrics into
their risk modeling and prefer investing
in brands that have sustainability
commitments
and the second reason is we are living
in a pivotal decade in the fight against
climate change
startups and new businesses an
opportunity to take responsibility and
chart a sustainable course for our
planet in response to climate change
the trend is clear there is more need
for computational power than ever
particularly with an emerge and growth
of webstery Internet of Things data and
millions of users starting their Journey
with the cloud every month
money month ultimately means more
servers and therefore more energy
data centers in particular have proven
to be an area where Innovation can have
a major impact
for example in our own data centers in
2020 we had seven times the compute for
the same amount of electricity we once
used in 2015.
and for this reason we continue to have
sustainability as part of our core
Mission at Google we strive to build
sustainability into everything we do for
everyone every googler every user every
product every partner and every
community
from product design to manufacturing and
supply chain operations Google is
working to deliver the tools and
technologies that provide the data and
insights for most sustainable decision
making so together we can address
environmental and social impact at every
step of the journey
as of the beginning of 2023 Google is
operating the cleanest cloud in the
world
this is an example of Google's goal that
we're passing on to businesses that
choose to build with Google
efficient data centers help us better
serve our users in a more sustainable
way
Google data centers are twice as
efficient as an industry average for
Enterprise data centers
we also optimize our data Center's
cooling system with our own machine
learning technology
when it comes to controlling data
centers there are unique beasts millions
of components that are relatively fickle
to change in their environment
every 5 minutes our AI system grabs a
snapshot of thousands of centers
it fits the inputs to Natural networks
which predict potential outcomes of
different actions and best adjustment
this focus on Energy Efficiency Cascades
into the services that you can get from
Google cloud and therefore offer to your
end customers
Google was the first major company to
become carbon natural in 2007.
then in 2017 Google became the first
major company to achieve hundred percent
renewable energy
which means that compute data and
machine learning workloads which Powers
your business on Google Cloud have zero
net emissions
but they don't want to stop there our
moonshot is to power all of the
operations 24 7 365 on renewable energy
and the same grid as the energy is
consumed
our next goal is to operate carbon 3 24
7 by 2013. and by doing this we enable
businesses by default on Google Cloud to
hold their Green Technology page
learn more about Google's commitment to
sustainability at sustainability.google
in line with our sustainability strategy
go
sustainability Journey how do we do that
well we think about sustainability in
two domains
firstly we help your business to adopt
technology that reduces the immediate
impact of your it operations and lowers
the associated emissions
the work we've done on our own data
centers effectively reduces the
emissions of your it infrastructure
we call this digital sustainability
and then secondly we help organizations
to use our extensive data sets the data
processing capabilities of Google cloud
and our ecosystem of Partners to help
reimagine your operations and processes
to reduce your own carbon emissions we
call this operational sustainability
so how do you view and track your
digital sustainability on Google Cloud
well there are three key ways you can do
this
is with Google Cloud carbon footprint
which can be accessed directly from your
Google Cloud console and provides you
with an overview of the gross emissions
of your Cloud infrastructure you can
measure and visualize these emissions
per project location or Google Cloud
product and easily export this data to
bigquery for your business's carbon
accounting
it's available to all Google Cloud users
for free
from cloud carbon footprint you can
launch into recommendations which will
take you to our active assist
sustainability recommendations
active assist uses Advanced analytics
and machine learning to identify idle
projects and evaluates their impact on
carbon footprint then producers
recommendations to help you reduce your
it carbon foot print
and lastly whenever you are spinning up
a new resource whether it's compute
engine bigquery or Cloud run our region
picker helps you to optimize for Price
latency and carbon footprint when
choosing where to run your new workload
let's talk about operational
sustainability
we have and continue to build Google
Cloud solutions to help our customers
across all Industries to make informed
decisions and promote Health Care
outcomes for the planet
meet Google Earth's engine
over the past decade academics
scientists and ngos have used Google
Earth's engine and its Earth's
observation data to make meaningful
progress on climate research natural
resources protection carbon emissions
reduction and other sustainability goals
now with the power of Google cloud and
intelligence of Google Earth's engine we
are helping companies with a responsible
management of Natural Resources while
building sustainable business practices
that cut costs and comply with
regulations
Earth's engine combines a 70 plus
petabytes catalog of satellite imagery
ngospatial data sets with planetary
scale analysis capabilities
and of course a trusted Community with
50 000 sustainability focused monthly
active users
a great opportunity to join the
community focused on sustainability
social and environmental impact
today Google Earth engine serves users
from science to operational business
decision making for 30 years we have
been collecting petabytes of earth
science data to protest using algorithms
the Earth's engine API is available in
Python and JavaScript making it easy to
harness the power of Google's Cloud for
your own geospatal analysis
and it remains at no cost for non-profit
non-commercial and research projects
as two examples Global Forest watch and
U.S forest Service
Globus Forest work offers the latest
data technology and tools
that empowers people everywhere to
better protect forests
usfs reduces time to complete mission
critical tasks from months to hours the
Google Earth's engine Superior data
catalog and scalability with Google
Cloud's comprehensive platform
Industries can solve for common
environmental and climate risks at scale
it starts with leveraging Google's gear
spital data and applying Google's
Advanced Ai and ml capabilities to
identify the impact of sustainable
business practices on their top and
bottom line and on the planet
and if you wanted to see a real-life
example of Earth's engine power in
action let's take a look at Unilever a
global consumer goods company
Unilever wanted to know what percentage
of their raw materials are sourced from
deforestation free suppliers
and how they can improve that number
until recently many brands have found it
hard to get real-time reliable
visibility in the operations at a local
supplier level globally
Unilever and Google Cloud teamed up to
help Advance sustainable business
practices
using cloud computing satellite imagery
and AI to build a more holistic view of
the forests water cycles and
biodiversities that intersect Unilever
supply chain
if you've forgotten to the end of this
video and you still want to learn more
sustainability with Google
here are a few steps you can take
firstly visit
sustainability.google and
google.cloud.com forward slash
sustainability
check out our Hands-On guides and
walkthroughs in the description below
look into our accelerator program
climate change Europe and lastly reach
out and get connected with someone from
Google Cloud
next up we'll be looking into how you
can scale your databases globally with
Google Cloud spanner
the session will cover some common
challenges with traditional databases
and how Google Cloud spanner overcomes
those challenges
we'll look at when you should consider
scaling your databases as well as
migration and pricing options
and we'll demonstrate how to get started
with Google Cloud spanner don't forget
the like And subscribe to our YouTube
channel click on the Bell icon to get
notified each time a new video is posted
thank you stay tuned and we will see you
very soon in the next video
foreign
[Music]